hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be looking at
day number four from the 2020 us chess
championships the final two rounds
in the tournament unless there is
a tie now we're going to be looking at
a game from round number 11. white's
going to be played by alejandro ramirez
black's going to be played by jeffers
young the reason we're going over this
game is jeffrey sits one point behind
wesley so for
first place jeffrey can tie wesley so
wesley so is actually playing nakamura
in the 11th round
so jeffrey needs to win wesley so does
need to lose and then we would have
a tiebreaker and anytime especially
in a championship series a teenager does
extremely well
from the united states definitely wants
to cover that as much as possible
and jeffrey's doing exactly that so i
thought we'd see how he ends this and
then if there is a tiebreaker
i'll get into that at the end of the
video but alejandro starts out with the
move e4
and jeffrey responds with the sicilian
c5
white continues with knight 2 f3 d6 and
then
c3 not a very common move from white
attacking the sicilian defense d4
pretty much the most common play that
you'll see you could also if
white to be an adventurous play bishop
to b5
but maybe alejandro said hey i'm playing
against someone
opposite me on the virtual felt here and
i want to get pretty creative
play c3 then we have knight to f6
queen to c2 defending the pawn here on
e4
queen to c7 g3 preparing to feed and
cater the bishop here to
g2 pawn b6 and then
bishop to g2 now i study a lot of chess
openings it's what i really enjoy
about chess and see how different
players approach different openings see
the variations and
and just kind of how they come up with
new novel ideas
this is not an approach in the sicilian
defense that i see all that often don't
know if i've ever seen this
specific setup in the sicilian so very
interested to see
how these opponents attack this first we
see
bishop to b7 so both of the players
eyeing down on
these light squares you can see this
pawn here on e4
starting to stand out is a square that
both sides may want to attack or defend
the bishop
here on b7 attacking as well as the
knight here on
f6 white immediately comes up and plays
d3 to defend this
and jeffrey comes down to c4 and attacks
the pawn here
now there is an exchange that does open
up for the queen to
defend this but you can see now that the
queen comes down there's a queen
bishop and knight all attacking this
pawn here
on e4
now my assumption is that alejandro
played this
opening because the move knight to d2 is
pretty tricky
and if black's not prepared for this can
fall into
a lot of mistakes you can already see
that the bishop
knights and queen here are all attacking
this pawn on e4 and it's overloading
the square and white can't defend it
with just the queen and even the knight
here on d2 that's only two pieces but
this knight is attacking the queen
black could feel overconfident and
actually take with the bishop here on e4
saying yeah i'm attacking your queen so
even if you take my queen i can just
take your queen right here
that's not necessarily a bad thing and
black was able to capture this material
here on e4
but instead white can take here on e4
and after the queen takes a queen takes
the knight takes here on e4
it looks like black came up in the
exchange
but then knight two d2 and this is where
black loses because if you start to
analyze where does black really go from
here well
if the knight moves then you can see the
bishop is going to just take
the rook here on a8 so that's not going
to work out well
if they tried to defend this pawn to
d5 okay we'll just knight takes here if
the pawn takes bishop recaptures and the
rook is going to fall
so that's not going to work out well so
at the end of the day
although black does have a ton of
material that's actually aimed
at the e4 square the best move now that
the queen is under attack is just to
retreat that's exactly what jeffrey does
he
understands the threat and correctly
moves the queen back to
c7 still putting a lot of pressure on
the e4 square so something that white
needs to be aware of
but jeffrey does retreat for the time
being
now knight to d7
work over here to e1 protecting the pawn
that we talked about here
g6 preparing to fianchetto to the king
side of the board
a4 since you've already castled start to
attack on the queen side bishop to
g7 pawn a5 rook to
c8 having the queen and the rook on the
semi-open
file looking to attack if needed pawn
takes here
pawn takes on b6 knight to
d4 really trying to figure out where
white goes from here
this knight on d2 it is protecting the
pawn on e4 but it's also awkwardly
placed because it's blocking in the dark
square bishop jeffrey's done a good job
besides castling of getting all the
material involved into the game
where white's kind of blocking off both
of his bishops so starts out with knight
2 d4 that unblocks the bishop here on
g2 queen comes back to b8
i want to make way for the rook to
attack i usually want to be using your
queen later in the game
but you want your rook to be the main
one attacking the semi-open and open
files pawn 2 b3 so opening up if the
bishop wants to come either to b2
or a3 castle on the king side and then
knight to
c4 so couple options that white now has
as far as where the dark bishop needs to
get involved so understanding
the development that he needs and doing
exactly that
we see rook 2 e8 bishop here to
a3 knight taking here on
e4 so we start to see an attack from
jeffrey in the center of the board
rook takes here on e4 bishop takes
queen takes here on e4 and then knight
to
c5 and it this is also an interesting
spot where sometimes
i think people could make a mistake and
they say okay well
i'm just going to go ahead and take with
my bishop here on e4 this would actually
be
a big mistake because the bishop can
take here
on d4 so after bishop takes
then the pawn recaptures and all of a
sudden this
knight is pinned to the queen here on
c2 and anytime a piece
is pinned down to a more powerful piece
like a queen
or a king you always want to attack that
if you can attack it with a pawn
that is priority numero uno so that
would be exactly what jeffrey would do
in this spot he would play pawn
to b5 in the night would
fall so sometimes that is pretty tricky
to
think ahead as far as oh wow if i
actually take with my bishop
then they can take and it's going to
create that
pin here but being a top class player
that's exactly what alejandro looks at
and he
correctly takes with his queen here on
e4
knight to c5 attacking the queen queen
comes back to e3
knight takes here on b3
and then we have knight coming back here
taking on
uh b3 but that also leaves this
knight here on a c4 so lots of
exchanging on the board here night now
coming here to d4 this is an outpost but
obviously can take with the bishop if
jeffrey wants to pawn down here to b5
so both solidifying this is an outpost
not generally the piece that you're
having an outpost with your pawn it's
usually going to be a bishop or
a knight but either way it's still
protected here
on c4 then we see the bishop come up
here to
d5 attacking the rook so the rook comes
over here attacks this bishop
here on a3 bishop comes down b3 attacks
the rook
rook retreats to a6 knight down to
c2 and as we've kind of talked about in
the past once your opponent starts to
retreat their knights
that's an opportunity to start to attack
jeffrey starts to push forward with his
pawn here on
e6 we see the rook swing over here to e6
doubling up the queen
and the rook and then queen to a7 just
says hey if you want to exchange that's
fine and this really comes into the
endgame of
what jeffrey feels like he is going to
do the best at
and you can see that from white's
perspective
he has two minor pieces and on the other
side
in exchange for those two minor pieces
you're really looking at a rook
and two pawns so that feels like a win
for jeffrey so that's why he decided to
go and exchange off the queens
both sides continue to exchange off
material
bishop takes here on d6 also leaves the
pawn here on
c3 vulnerable bishop takes here on c3
rook to b1 it's under attack here rook 2
d8 attacking the bishop
bishop comes back so white does have the
bishop pair
but at the end game two rooks together
are definitely a powerful powerful
weapon
as well as having the bishop as well
rook over here to d7 getting them both
on this open file on the center of the
board definitely a good strategy
knight to a3 and then just comes down b4
great outpost for the bishop here
on c3 knight 2
c4 and then a rook over here to a7
king to f1 trying to get involved into
the game once the queens come off the
board a little bit safer to get the
kings towards the center of the board it
becomes a very powerful piece
and an attack here rook down to a1 says
yeah
i'm fine exchanging material here bishop
takes on a one
king to e2 uh bishop here to c3 so i
would give jeffrey a slight advantage i
do think the rook
is a very very powerful piece in this
setup
but it's going to be very difficult for
jeffrey to find
a victory here knight 2
e5 starting to attack this
f7 square at some point then we have
rook
2 a8 and then king
2 d3 and this is the decisive move
in the game here because if we look at
this position right here
knight 2 e5 this is
pretty dangerous for white and jeffrey
recognizes some of the threats that he
has
here because you always want to look at
what's protecting the material
and this knight right here is protected
by the bishop on f4
and black can actually play pawn to g5
as a deflection move and that's going to
force this bishop away from protecting
the knight
now in this specific position white can
just take
the pawn on g5 and then it's attacking
the rook here on d8 it has to move so
while the knight's no longer protected
the knight is going to be fine because
the rook has to move but
jeffrey decided to go ahead and play
rook to a8 he
saw the potential threat of g5 but he
had to get the rook out of the way
but then king 2 d3 is a massive error
really white needed to play knight to
d3 probably the only saving move that he
has because
after knight to d3 now g5
and in this spot alejandro ramirez
decided to resign because there's just
no way to
continue in this spot if he plays knight
takes on f7 just says okay
something's gonna fall here then just
take the bishop maybe the knight comes
back that's fine
rook to d8 check but this in game
jeffrey should easily win and
if the bishop moves that's fine then
you're just going to see the bishop take
here on e5
so at the end of the day jeffrey wins so
kudos to him unfortunately for him
wesley so ended up
drawing against nakamura
and so wesley so is the champion
definitely needed
a loss from wesley so for a tiebreaker
thought that would have been truly
awesome to see if the teenager could
have
pulled it out now those two did actually
play that was the only loss that jeffrey
had was playing wesley so
if he could have drawn that one then we
also would have had a tiebreaker at the
very end with those two but
hopefully everyone enjoyed this
tournament always nice to see
people in the u.s chess championship
especially that the younger players
do extremely well hopefully they can do
that at the
the greater international stage as well
but this is always a fun tournament for
me to analyze hopefully enjoyed it as
well
again thanks for supporting the channel
if you haven't already please subscribe
also would be so kind of you if you hit
that like button
to let me know that you like the video
and the series that we did
on the us chess championship but thanks
again for watching
i'll see you guys in the next video